did I just hear someone use a
microaggression microaggression it's a
term we all came to hum but what does it
really mean let's do a quick simple
google search to find out what is a
microaggression sleep what is a micro
Enzo a microaggression
is this what is in micro a salt anymore
what is a microwave alligator boy
mackerel aggression some little micro
aggressions macro assault hurts Michaels
regression oh my god okay all right
we're gonna have to take a step back
micro aggression is the term coined in
1970 but recently God pop realized
thanks to this wonderful man let's see
how he describes it a good day everyone
my name is Derald wing sue why does this
feel like a comedy sketch it feels like
I'm watching adults with you share with
you some of the harmful impact that
micro aggressions have on music
authorities in our society it's a good
thing get outs will micro aggressions
are the everyday slights indignities put
downs and insults that people of color
women LGBT populations or those who are
marginalized experienced in their day to
day interactions with people in this
scene johnny has finished a late night
at the office and awaits the elevator I
can tell it's a very late night based on
the darkness so door opens he takes one
step forward sees a black male rider
hesitates and immediately clutches her
purse and places her hand over her
necklace
the hidden communication is that
african-americans are prone to crime
will break the law are up to no good and
will steal okay I have taken a couple
classes in microaggressions and
basically here we go micro aggression it
can be divided into three
based on if it's a intentional
microaggression or an unconscious
microaggression if it's an unintentional
microaggression then it's called a micro
invalidation whatever the heck that is
and then if it's intentional it's a
micro assault and if it's somewhere in
between you will find a micropenis just
kidding and Mike it's a micro insult in
the middle if you're not okay these
jokes are so [ __ ] bad my god now you
might think that micro aggression is not
that big a deal
not people don't use it seriously come
on Felix so recent TV went to a campus
to do some research Occidental College
in California is considering instituting
a system for students to report
so-called microaggressions oh wow I
believe the most qualified person should
get the job qualifications aren't really
the only the only things you consider
when hiring someone how can you say that
how can you even hesitate on their
qualifications aren't really the only
the only things you consider when hiring
someone what else is there if you're
running a business you want the most
qualified person for the job
right you know I just hear someone use a
microaggression
I understand not wanting to hire the
same type of people because then you're
just gonna get the same type of opinion
but the quote most qualified person
surely if you have if you get a job you
should get it knowing I was the most
qualified for this job
qualifications are really the only the
only things you consider when hiring
someone I was so confused
if you're saying that the most qualified
person is someone who is not a minority
you're not a religion you believe and
then yes I'd be a microaggression
but that's not what they were saying
saying god bless you after somebody
sneezes oh that would be a
microaggression
because
different religions yeah it could be a
microaggression to someone who doesn't
believe in God
I think that the harm there is
relatively minimal so there's still some
harm though definitely harm I feel my
hope my soul is burning my soul is on
fire I truly feel what it's like to be
marginalized could be a microaggression
to someone who doesn't believe in God
it could be a microaggression to someone
who doesn't believe in God it reminds me
the other week when mr. Wil Wheaton who
has me blocked on Twitter for being
toxic tweeted right after the church
shooting in Texas that the murdered
victims would still be alive if prayers
did anything that seems like the good
time as any to criticize prayers after a
church shooting thing is I don't believe
in religion I am what yeah agnostic
atheist but I don't feel the need to
criticize other people if people want to
say thoughts and prayers to something
bad happening I know they have a good
intention in mind even though I don't
believe in what that good intention is I
don't feel the need to go against a and
the same thing with God bless you you
know someone means something well why
would I personally turn I would be the
one responsible for turning it into
something negative and that's the thing
with microaggression is that it's a game
that anyone can play but no one wins I
have an accent like a like a Swedish
accent oh did you just assume my accent
never never have I been so shook I'm
shook I'm Chuck Swedish accent excuse me
just cuz I had this fake blonde hair
just not me no service like a Swedish
accent yeah
not everyone in Sweden is blonde okay
what microaggressions are the everyday
slights indignities put downs for those
who are marginalized experienced in
their day-to-day interactions with
people I'm not ignoring that these are
could be hurtful for a lot of people I I
fully understand that I'm not trying to
take that away from people they have the
right to feel whatever the way
they want to feel but I found it really
interesting in this video when they talk
about free speech what are your thoughts
on the concept of free speech do you
support free speech yes I do support
free speech everyone should be able to
say what they believe in what's on their
mind Alexis and microaggression then we
need to report it for hate speech I
support free speech but it doesn't work
like that we condemn freedom of speech
that hurt other people's feelings why
don't you suck my micropenis in drawled
wing Sue's one of his books he points
out that micro aggression produce
physical health problems and shorten
life expensi and the general consensus
from research is that there's no
evidence to back up that micro
aggressions is actually harmful and what
is actually defined who does it actually
affect some say it could even be more
harmful to use the term now now that we
know about micro aggression we're gonna
play a little game it's called can you
spot the micro aggression a McGill
student was forced to apologise for
racial microaggression after emailing
joke obama clip this was an
unintentional micro aggression which we
now learn it's a micro invalidation good
job class you learned a lot here today
it was posted with the caption honestly
midterms
get out of here write down in the
comments what the micro aggression was
right now
[Music]
it was based on the fact not that
midterms are frustrating then you need
to get that anger out it was Blackman
angry
am i right micro aggression we also have
this clip from the diversity Council of
Australia pain project that we're
working on is actually looking at how we
come on girls
let's get cracking girls the micro
aggression here is of course a little
bit more subtle for their untrained eye
but me as an micro aggressing expert I
can easily tell you that this micro
aggression is based on the fact that
[Music]
they all look like girls and could it be
the Kraken get crackin come on girls
let's get cracking like a cracker white
stir it now moving on this is posted on
BuzzFeed about micro aggression examples
no you're white moving on so what do you
guys speak in Japan Asian micro
aggression just because I'm Somali
doesn't mean I know any pirates this guy
is clearly just taking a piss I mean
look at his face come on let me just
play this micro violin for all these
poor people with the science and my god
they must be tough I get it you know
actually it's it's smaller than that
it's super micro yeah actually it's so
tiny it's it's a nano aggression all
right okay all right okay let's get
serious now and this might be completely
based on my Swedish cookery and I can't
help it but I always try to be somewhat
sensible and around all these ideas I'm
not dismissing the fact that this is a
problem but calling it a micro
aggression implies that there's violence
involved and that somehow you have the
right to strike back against it
with violence as well which is the joke
that South Park hold when hitting anyone
in the game for making a microaggression
when in reality it's just an insult
excuse me did you or did you not say
that this man seemed tired yes he's my
friend I said Paulo you look tired
microagressions persons of Hispanic
backgrounds have been stereotyped as
being sleepy and saying they look tired
as a micro aggression that will not
Stern but I am tired and it's not a
matter of definition I think it's a you
can call it micro whatever that's not
really the issue I think the issue is
how you're approaching a problem if
people want to remove micro aggression
from campus I don't really have a
problem with that shouldn't that be done
through educating instead of trying to
police because it isn't educating what
you do at a campus any form of social
study and social justice these days just
seems to be about policing and haha we
got you shame rather than educating and
trying to explain why something is bad
now excuse me while I go and cry some
micro tears thank you for leaving a like
on this video every like is a macro
compliment
I would really much appreciate it thank
you very much for subscribing that would
be a mega compliment really appreciate
it and as always remember to gladly be
nice